hello and welcome to this video playing
Yardbird for the first time since quite
a while I haven't played him recently I
1-4 against him 20 22.5 out of 49 it's
be really one of the most frequent
opponents and so we get a mainline place
t3 normally yeah d three children it's
not exactly exciting but certainly solid
for white but awkwarder that pinning
situation
no what can you do
so should be should be a huge deal
ok so what to do a 95 is annoying relief
let's go possible queen bee three is
maybe the self I don't know stepping out
of them possible 95 move I can take up
six this is actually pretty good for him
now k it's not that bad I thought that
95 then is a bit I mean annoying it is
anyway but
okay I really hate to play that but if
you gets to click on b5 it looks in even
more problematic so okay I think I
should take one of the night sir that's
probably a good idea okay I'm see going
to the annex to this going to go to d5
with the Queen at some point I don't
know I this shouldn't be so bad really
but don't believe that this is a huge
problem okay now basically have to go
back home right afterward why not
let's keep d4 under control
my ideas rook a7b sounds this kind of
thing can I go queen bee five instead of
move quicker now now probably not
hmm
cannot Google b7 unfortunately as a six
hangs this is a bit bit of a problem
maybe tegan quin be five is that a move
takes a takes the a pawn it's not clear
that this is a big big strength I'm
yeah this is the simple way to do it and
probably not a bad way unfortunately so
what about this now the cheek there the
anti still he is invading here I'd like
to play before some somehow if it's
possible before takes takes Knight takes
Knight 85
now d5 still very very awkward okay
anyway very awkward but may be possible
to hold ideas rupee rook 637 and look b7
something like that and here the
question is to see you have something
here or not you mean it's not obviously
not a lot and what it's just a little
bit more active but maybe you can still
do something I cannot move the night
let's see ain't time morning so is happy
to win the porn
yeah the main problem is that my time is
not grade 5 against Floyd's more winning
chances and for against three but it's
still a draw if you played right and
have some time now maybe you can go out
for something should probably go behind
the pawns and not stay on the third rank
okay here for I can take and then go
back to the H pawn check and all right
expect the King to get the good deep
hole check now I'm getting some player
against g3 or not okay check
check check check check okay this is the
question on Kenny can you decide the
game now with this with this pawn push
maybe you can check check cut the age
porn count and play I think it wrong or
is it maybe not is very close check no
man to f12 f1 and it's just a draw I'm
such an idiot no come on this is this is
silas sucks for its own time that just
sucks ah stupid stupid ok how can i go
to h3 I've got eight seconds this is
easy just this end it's a draw how it
should be ah come on ah as it's like
wasted ten minutes yeah you defend the
whole time in a bad position and get the
draw and then you play king edge 3f and
it's so off it's immediately obvious
that it loses
check there's also sham times the
phenomenon and blitz yeah you really
know it was you still play idea you play
and you Mircea why not kick everyone
yeah okay well it was a somewhat bad
position you wonder around here didn't
feel like I should have some trouble but
here that was not easy the computer
wants to do this I ok m IC night here
Andrew piayed again this is this am
pretty comfortably holding him because
why does a bit out of ideas if he takes
before I can take with the night I mean
this would even be verse 5 of course so
that it's completely useless yeah 96 I
just I can even take a 5-4 huh but this
is also ok and wrote here I felt it
should be like that but I didn't find
the right continuation and here of
course he is just better a 6 was winning
it seems yeah i was on a huge huge huge
pressure here so i know i got this book
and gave all of it check really not sure
if this check this is giving any any
substantial winning chance i don't think
so check check check check check
yeah yeah I felt I should be losing
somehow the engine gives rupee 7 as a
win I it's difficult to trust the
computer here if it just them is on for
a couple of seconds check e seven is
seven did win yo be 70 spin if the cop
is giving plus 50 years it's a win and
now i'm doing them i'm just-just
agenting how can you play king age 3 is
just stupid just totally stupid this is
totally obvious obviously a draw thanks
for watching